Ian Lick: For many people
The method used and controlled by your application can be classified in a two-way,
Either browsing through the content, or through search oriented content.
If your app does not provide a good search experience inside
If you are serving only part of the user base.
Hi, I'm Ian Lick, and I want to see you
What you need to build a great in-app search experience
Using SearchView , to help users access
What they want exactly in the easiest way possible.
Basic building units for a good search experience
Start with the hardest one, the good content.
We are talking about searching using a single query thread.
But how this is reflected on your data
Whether it is a user list or a full-text search publication
How to store all this data is under your control.
Well, it may be helpful to have a full search text
Feature, or FTS table exists locally on your computer.
If your data set is small enough, search speed is important.
Let's focus on the search process at the moment.
Because the search is a pivotal routing style,
It makes sense to standardize a single pattern to provide search.
In android, including SearchView
Typically, SearchView is considered as Action in the main application bar
Or in an appropriate taskbar.
By clicking the SearchView icon
SearchView expands, allowing the user to search immediately.
Through AppCompat , part of the Android support library,
SearchView is now available in all Android 2.1 and higher devices.
Add SearchView to your application bar
Adding an item only adds to the list you are adopting.
Next to the title and icon are more obvious.
You will notice that ShowAsAction contains collapseActionView
This is what tells the list that this element must involve
In normal, but can be extended to the specified ActionViewClass specified.
We also need ifRoom or instead showAsAction
Without this, our icon will appear only in the overflow dropdown list
And we will not be able to extend it to the full SearchView .
And we do not want that.
With this extension only, we get a nice search code
Expands to SearchView ,
But the search does not go anywhere or do anything else.
We can get a reference when we open our list,
But what are we doing here?
First, there is a full manual mode,
SetOnQueryTextListener .
Here you will find a retrieval to change the search text
When the user submits his search,
Giving you full control over what happens and when it happens.
You can take advantage of more when it provides a searchable installation.
This is the XML file, specifically
For all the various options associated with the search.
So many options that we have a full documentation page
For all varied options, 9 pages of detailed explanations.
Fortunately, it is also possible to be very short and easy.
Just a tag, which is often the name of your application,
And a hint of research publications
Or search for the name of your application.
Evaluate what it takes to add a search search to your SearchView ?
Just one extra line for your searchable structures.
This is a very strong line, but remember that voice search
Enter directly what is being said.
There is no chance to change things before input,
Make sure your search is sound before you activate it.
This will then link the searchable structure actively.
This is the activity you want to go to
When the user enters a search.
You will notice that we are using SingleTop launch mode.
This is important if you have SearchView
For your searchable activity, let's say, to do a second search.
This launch mode prevents a huge amount of potential search results.
Link your SearchView , installable searchable
SearchManager Search Manager is used
System service that distributes the additional data element
Which you have added to one of your activities and creates searchable information
You can drag it to your SearchView .
This triggers the searchable activity.
But to extract the real search text, look for ACTION_SEARCH
Then we draw the research from the additional content.
This calls it onCreate
And if you are using SingleTop firing mode
Called from onNewIntent also.
So you have a great looking SearchView
Which is directly looking for the activity of our choice.
What we have not yet talked about is the new search suggestions.
Or revised proposals
Which makes it easier for users to find what they want.
Check out the developer's website for more information.
I can not wait to see great experiences
Which you will create using the internal application search during your search
To build better applications.